beautiful bays
crystal clear water and mild
temperatures all year round
the east coast of cyprus is a favorite
destination for seaside vacationers
one of the island's most idyllic beaches
is fig tree bay
a lot of people come from everywhere to
see the area here
they come to victory bay i have their
water sports since
1975 i used to be in the middle of the
beach
i used to have one boat one pedal
one canoe and a few
wind surfing boards that's it now you
see
what we have those who are looking for a
bit of culture head southwest
to the port city of larnica
the main landmark of the old quarter is
the 9th century church of saint lazarus
hotels line the promenade along
finocuda's beach
named for the palm trees planted along
the shore
boat rides leave the harbor for an
underwater tourist attraction
the xenobia is the largest wreck in the
mediterranean that can be reached by
scuba
it sank in 1980 just two kilometers off
larnica
with more than 100 trucks on board
people travel from other countries to
visit zenobia that is full of groupers
barragudas the marine life down there is
amazing
we are talking about the wreck that is
180 meters so we talk about the mountain
of steel under the water
uh it's something unique for tires okay
guys make your way down and get yourself
sorted out please oh i'm quite nervous
because it's so deep
all of the participants have to prove
that they've got a certain number of
scuba diving hours to be allowed to
explore the zenobia even the pros have
to make the dive
with an instructor
the more experienced divers can go all
the way down
to the hold of the zenobia at a depth of
40 meters
novices stay near the shipwreck surface
about 15 meters deep
it was huge it was really really massive
yeah i love that
further inland there's plenty more to
discover
cyprus has the most extensive forests of
any mediterranean island
at the foot of the trodos mountains lie
a number of idyllic villages
one of the oldest is lafu with its
typical stone houses and narrow alleys
here they brew coffee according to
cypriot tradition
in a copper pot on a bed of hot sand
a few kilometers away wineries produce
one of the oldest wines in the world
comanderia it's a sweet wine made
nowhere else but here
for almost 3 000 years when the gravy is
very sweet we harvest the grapes
and we lay under the strong sun in those
days there is really strong
sunlight for eight to ten days
the sun the graves will lose a lot of
moisture
because of evaporation
and after we collect and take to the
winery where we crash and take the juice
immediately
the grapes are sun-dried and that gives
the wine its amber color
its higher alcohol content also means it
keeps for longer periods of time
after a wine tasting it's worth a trip
westward to aphrodite's rock
this is where the goddess of love is
said to have emerged from the sea
one of many legends surrounding the site
we've heard about the legend and you're
supposed to swim
three times uh clockwise three times
uh counterclockwise and you'll be young
forever
um we haven't done we haven't done it
yet
so let's just say tomorrow okay yeah
tomorrow
according to another variant couples who
swim around the rock will be blessed
with eternal love
and even if the eternal love or eternal
youth doesn't work out
you'll still be rewarded with a
spectacular sunset